See you man.
Good to see you.
I purposely didn't ask you or talk to you about the grizzly bear attack cause I
wanted to save it.
You want it,
you want,
what is it like to have survived but literally being two feet away from an
attack and grizzly close if you could have grabbed it.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Easily.
Oh it was,
that was just nuts.
It was one of those things.
Okay.
I've thought about it a million times.
I'm sure.
How long ago was this?
This was,
so that would have been early October or mid October.
So you've had two or three months.
Three months to California.
Yep.
And uh,
yeah man,
it's just one of those things that I've thought about it so many times in my
head and I've always been,
I think Steve was the same way.
Like,
oh,
it'd be pretty cool to,
uh,
survive a bear attack.
Get scratched up a little bit after that experience.
I thought to myself,
if that never happens,
you know me.
Okay.
Yeah.
Steve,
you so always say Steve or no,
we're talking about from the immediate or podcasts and he has a two part series
on this particular bear attack,
but he always say he wanted to get clawed across the chest and have like not a
tattoo,
but like a big cough.
Get a marking like w what are the odds that that happens?
Yeah,
I think that in order to get that you have to go through a really,
really horrible experience and there's guys that have had those attacks or
there's guys that have had those detects a lot.
But yeah,
I mean I've been around a lot of wild animals and seen a lot of things and been
charged by bears and this was just different.
It was that kind of attack where while it's happening,
you're going,
this is not gonna Pan out.
Well,
somebody is going to die something either you're just looking at this bear and
it's coming in hot and just everything.
It's a weird experience.
You don't,
your memory's a little foggy of it and everything happened so fast,
but it felt like it was so long.
So the adrenaline must have overwhelming.
Yeah.
And you don't even think about,
I just remember it was,
it was a weird situation.
So maybe I'll just kind of recap the story.
Um,
so we're,
we're on a fog neck island and we're hunting in a fog.
Mac Island is off a Kodiak.
Yeah.
So a fog neck island has some of the largest bears in the world.
They're brown bears there.
They are big brown bears and it can be over a thousand pounds.
So we're hunting elk there.
My brother and myself have hunted elk on that island before and it's just a
miserable place to be.
What's a fascinating hunt the way you guys were describing it,
because the,
the,
just the fact that you would choose out of all the places you can go,
you pretty much can go anywhere you want.
Yeah.
You chose to go on this brutal adventure hunt because it's so difficult once is
it?
Because like Rinella was talking about this once and the way he described it as
like,
there's things that are fun while you're doing them,
but they're not fun later.
Like rollercoasters.
Yeah.
And then there's things that are terrible and awful,
but you'll think about them forever and look back at them fondly.
Yeah,
that's exactly what this is,
is that,
uh,
after the fact,
you think back and you get them in the moment,
you go,
I will never do this again.
And then about a year later,
yeah,
we should do that again.
It's weird.
And what is it about the place it's so miserable?
Well,
it's just,
it's hard to walk through it.
It looks,
it looks easy hiking and there's just this big mountain where you can get to
with a plane,
you've kind of got to climb this big mountain and the vegetation is so thick and
it's so steep that it takes forever to go somewhere.
So to put it in perspective,
to go say a mile might take five hours.
Whoa.
That's how much vertical,
like a map mile.
So the way the crow would fly if you're just going a mile and then another
distance could take you half that time or a quarter of that time.
But there's a big mountain in between where you need to go plus the vegetation.
And it's really steep.
So you've got all that kind of working against you.
Plus you can't really walk and just a straight line there.
You've got to navigate around all kinds of,
definitely as you from play some of this Jamie,
that was z droid and
rough gay.
So that was after the bear attack.
Well,
I'll have to figure out,
cause I pope right after the bear attacked,
I pulled out my phone and it was just kind of like recording everyone's
reactions and then I put it on my Instagram story,
but I'll,
I'll try to find it tonight and I'll post it on to some,
I'll figure out a way to,
yeah,
it's instigates stories.
They let you save them now.
Now they say,
yeah,
this was like three weeks before that,
unfortunately.
So this place is miserable.
It's rainy all the time.
High winds,
thick,
dense vegetation and literal monsters.
Yeah.
I mean giant bears and then big,
um,
the elk are probably with they way they wait,
they can wait up to 1400 pounds,
these elk.
So sex is way bigger.
Yeah.
It was like the size of two normal elk weight-wise cause like an average elk
would probably be around 500 pounds in most places.
Really big one.
Like we were talking about the California ones that to hone sometimes can get to
a thousand this is another 400 pounds.
Big.
Exactly.
It's a lot.
It's a big game and there's bears eat those giant ant giant.
The the barriers can be over 1200 1500 pounds themselves.
11 feet.
Yeah.
11 feet and feet.
It's nuts.
11 foot bear.
Nope.
This one that attacked you guys.
How big do you think it was if you had to guess?
I would say,
well I would say it's 11 and a half feet.
No,
because actually after we went in there,
my friend who's a pilot there and dropped us off,
he called me about a week or two later and he's like,
they shot that bear that when after you guys,
somebody went in there,
same place.
Bear attacked him.
They killed it in self defense.
It was 11 and a half feet and I think almost 1200 pounds.
So there's very good odds that that was the same bear.
I would imagine that it was.
There's a very,
I mean cause I just,
same area,
same area had taken over that area,
seemed about the same sock when I,
when it came in,
I thought that's a big bore.
It wasn't one of those ones you think,
oh that's a,
it looked like a big mature animal
in there piecing together what happened in my mind later.
But yeah,
so we're hunting elk on this island.
Stephen's up getting an l,
we hang it in the tree.
We do all the stuff you're supposed to do,
get the meat away from the carcass.
But we had yet to see a bear up until this point.
And when my brother and I went in there a few years earlier,
we just saw bears every day.
We'd see six beers a day.
So your mind's just bear,
bear,
bear.
When you're seeing him all the time,
when you weren't seeing him all the time,
you get a little lax and that's where we really screwed up because the attack
went down.
No one was prepared.
We were just sitting around having some sandwiches and one of the,
so we're,
we're,
we're filming and there was six of us all together and I think that large group,
that six is what saved us because when the bear Ranney and it was six of us
sitting kind of in like a semi circle strange circle.
And when that bear came in we did that scatter effect and I think that scatter
was kind of like if a lion is going after a zebra,
they use their numbers and stripes to confuse the lion is that scattering of
things just going everywhere that that caused confusion for the bear.
So I think the bear went in thinking whatever's under that tree,
I'm going to kill it.
And it thought it was one thing and when we blew up into six different pieces,
it just tried to kill everything at once and couldn't actually get one person,
God.
But so lucky.
Yeah,
it was crazy because we're sitting down,
we decided,
oh we'll have lunch before we hiked back.
Cause the day before we,
we hiked along ways.
We got back to camp at three in the morning or something.
I can't remember,
two or three in the morning,
we'd barely eaten.
So everyone was just thinking,
let's have lunch,
regroup,
hike out.
So we're pat when the other guys that was with us brought the jet boiled boil up
some coffee.
So I was going around collecting water from everyone to get coffee going around.
And when I sat down,
I took my pack off and I,
the whole week I've been doing this thing where I take my pistol from the PAC
belt and put it on the holster on my body.
When I dropped my pack and I,
it was that weird deal where I took the pack off and I'm thinking about
switching and I'm like,
no,
it's fine.
You know?
And I thought,
I'll just sit,
because there's few times I'd set my pack down and I was like,
I'll just sit a lay on my pack,
like as a chair,
a backrest,
and then I'll flop the,
you know,
have the pistol right there so it's within arms reach and I'll be sitting there
while I go around and get the water.
And then someone had moved kind of where I was sitting.
So now,
so I sit down across from the pack where my pistol is and then thinking,
and I was thinking about,
Oh hey,
hand me that pistol.
But I just was like,
Eh,
you know,
you don't want to be that guy.
Like oh yeah,
the guys that need it.
Exactly right.
We did not,
everybody had pistols,
just me and Yanna set a pistol and then,
and then Pat's behind us.
He goes,
I hear something and I look up and that's,
that bears like dead set.
So Steve would be where you are.
The bear behind Steve.
So like Steve was between me and the bear,
his back was to it.
Like how far away?
Not Far,
I dunno,
30 yards or something the first time you see that 30 yards.
Yeah,
it's dead run super fast.
And I just locked eyes with this thing.
I mean I see it coming in the whole way,
just bdis locked in on me and I think this is going to kill me.
And so I'm thinking,
you know,
when I say I'm thinking,
I don't know if I'm thinking,
I'm just,
I just remembered what I was kind of going through my head at the time.
I thought,
Oh fuck,
I'm gonna die.
And my protections right there like I'm going to die.
This is that situation where I'm dead.
And they talk about it and he could have saved himself,
but his guns on the ground.
And I think that that was like,
go for the gun was my whole thing.
So I start to go for the gun.
You honestly would have been here as I remember it.
And so I start to go for the gun and realized,
fuck,
I don't have time to get to my gun.
And it's three feet away to that bears right there comes down on me so fast.
So I kind of do like a football juke move left,
right.
And then wheel around right.
Do like a spin with my back and they start running to the left.
And at that point Yonis it,
I,
I didn't know this at the time cause I looked at some pictures afterwards,
kind of piece everything together.
So Yannis was sitting right next to me.
I think he got up to turn.
There were some trekking poles right here.
He grabbed a trekking pole.
So probably while I was joking,
he reached around and grabbed the trekking pole,
swings around,
hits the bear in the face.
She's so then the IC,
the bear running off.
Then I see someone going down the mountain with the bear.
I'm thinking he's got someone.
So I grabbed my pistol,
start going down the mountain yelling,
Oh,
count off,
I guess I count off.
And everyone's like,
Whoa,
whoa.
And I'm like,
Oh shit.
Who's missing.
Right.
And then Garrett pops up out of the bushes and his,
he's like,
why he died?
So Garrett,
Ak dirt,
dirt myth.
He's the one who was on top of the,
somehow he's on the barriers back.
So I think when the bear wheeled around you like hit him and he ends up on the
back.
So I saw just legs and bear going down the,
I saw his legs on the back of the bear scene.
Maybe the bear had him in his job.
Yeah,
that's what I was thinking.
Wow.
I mean,
who would think
like if that was in a movie you'd be like,
get the fuck outta here.
I think what was the anchorman where the guy's like,
you're riding the bear.
It's exactly like,
yes.
And then we just kind of circled up around the tree and the real scary part was
that bear.
Why it was so thick.
You really couldn't see.
And you could see maybe as far as the Wallace from us,
which was that the true eight feet.
Yeah.
And just real thick brush.
And you'd hear the bear charge.
And again,
and we only have the two pistols Yiannis and I and the the,
the wind was so strong,
there's no way we could use bear spray.
So we hear the bay charging in and me and Yannis or like pistols out ready,
waiting for this thing to pop out at point blank range and then it would,
and you were yelling
and then that thing stops and then it would just crash off and then it would
charge in from the other direction.
She ain't gotta like circle around the tree the other way and did that,
I think three times.
That was just a nerd.
It's like a horror movie where it keeps coming in from different angles.
It was weird.
It was not a fun feeling.
You just felt so small.
So you guys had come back to the carcass that was hanging in the tree and it had
probably claim that carcass.
We don't know it knew the glorious was there.
I assume now the weird thing was is it came in with the wind,
so the wind was blowing pretty stiff and say into our face and the bear came in
with the wind,
so he wasn't going into the scent.
Normally they go around,
they catch the scent and they charge in.
So I don't know if you'd heard something if he was there.
We saw what slightly looked like bare sign.
Both Steve and Steve and I kind of pointed it out,
but we weren't,
we were thinking maybe it was something older you wouldn't you say bear sign?
You mean bear shit?
Yeah,
bear shit in the base of the tree.
Yeah.
And so I think,
you know,
we did some things that were wrong,
but in,
in the instance what saved us all now if we were to do it a hundred times over,
I would say I would do it differently.
But it worked out how it worked out.
So I obviously wouldn't,
I would never opt to just have nothing and have this weird scatter effect.
But I think that what saved everyone from getting anyone from getting hurt,
which is a miracle,
was the fact that when we scattered,
it just confused that bear because he kind of had this look after you started.
You started wheeling around kind of like trying to pick a person,
trying to go,
and he couldn't target one individual and then things started hitting him and
somebody is on his back and I think it just freaked him out and he went off to
regroup,
keep charging back in,
but never made that full charge all the way back in again.
Wow.
That's crazy.
How many people have ever gone through a bear attack?
Unscaved like that.
And a group of six.
Yeah,
and the thing about it was it wasn't just a bear attack,
but had looking at it later,
had someone even been grabbed and mauled,
not to death but injured,
I think that it would've been very unlikely that that person was survived
because we,
the weather that came in was so bad.
I don't know if it was a hundred mile an hour winds.
I mean,
you weren't getting rescued in a hundred mile an hour winds,
I wouldn't think,
I dunno those coast guard helicopters.
I'm not really sure what they're capable of.
Maybe someone would just say,
yeah,
we'd,
we'd go,
but that would be a very hard thing.